Amin wie hast du die Rede wie hast du
den Auftritt von Putin heute
erlebt das war eine sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftige oder sagen wir eine
ungewohnte Inszenierung Putin gab sich
ganz fast freundlich konziliant elders
statesman an Problemlösungen inszeniert
also das was wir eigentlich seit der dem
Konflikt um die Ukraine erlebt haben wie
wir ihn erlebt haben nämlich sehr
aggressiv anklagend immer wieder darauf
hinweisend die NATO wolle Russland
bedrohen die Ukraine wolle Russland
bedrohen der Westen hätte seine Zusagen
nicht eingehalten hätte belogen und
betrogen all das wurde gar nicht erwähnt
NATO USA diese Worte fielen gar nicht
auch Faschisten Nazis so bezeichnet er
ja oft die Regierung in der Ukraine all
diese Worte fielen gar nicht es war ein
ganz ungewohnter Putin Putin hat heute
dann aber auch noch gesagt beim G20
Gipfel man müsse Zitat die Tragödie in
der Ukraine beenden wie zynisch ist
diese
Aussage genau er hat ganz konkret
Entschuldigung er hat ganz konkret
gesagt wir müssen den Krieg beenden der
eine Tragödie ist und das ist natürlich
so wie du sagst an Zynismus schwer zu
überbieten aber man muss sehen Putin das
was wir hier gesehen haben das folgt
einem sehr kühlen knallharten Kalkül aus
kremmelsicht stockt die Gegenoffensive
in der Ukraine der Kremmel beobachtet
das im West Diskussionen aufkommen wie
lange können wir und wollen wir die
Ukraine unterstützen was ist überhaupt
das Ziel das nutzt er das ist jetzt sein
Zeitpunkt um mal zu testen wie weit kann
er gehen kann er zurück auf diese Bühne
dieser G20 Gipfel wurde von dem
indischen Regierungschef Modi inszeniert
zu Gunsten Putins das muss man ganz klar
sagen der hat ihm die Bühne gegeben es
wurde nacheinander gesprochen es konnte
eigentlich niemand Putin was
entgegensetzen weil jeder virtuell
seinen kleinen Vortrag Gehalt en hat und
dazu muss man wissen Indien ist der
größte Empfänger von russischen
Rohstoffen heutzutage und da hat der
Inder seinem Freund Putin offensichtlich
einen Gefallen getan unds erreicht h
noch eine Frage wie erklärt man Putins
virtuelle Präsenz auf dem Gipfel dazu
sei vielleicht noch gesagt es war
tatsächlich ein virtueller Gipfel also
es liegt jetzt nicht daran dass Putin
nicht hinfahren wollte sondern die
ganzen Staats- und Regierungschefs haben
sich virtuell
getroffen du hast es jetzt schon
bisschen aus genau ich würde aber s weit
gehen zu sagen dass das für ihn
inszeniert wurde ich würde seit gehen zu
sagen dass dieser Gipfel der unüblich
ist in dem Format stattfand damit er
eine Möglichkeit hat alle virtuell und
alle gleich okay ein wichtiger Punkt du
hast es gerade schon ein bisschen
angerissen also es war eine Inszenierung
und der Kremmel hat sich dabei auch
sicher was gedacht welches Signal davon
ausgehen soll sowohl nach außen als auch
nach innen vielleicht kannst du das noch
mal beschreiben welches Signal Putin
damit am auch sozusagen an die russische
Bevölkerung senden
will genau wir sind hier vier Monate vor
der russischen Präsidentschaftswahl die
ist für März angesetzt das heißt Putin
hat ein Bild inszeniert ich bin auf der
Bühne seht her ohne mich geht gar nichts
wenn die großen Führer der Welt die
Probleme der Welt besprechen sitze ich
zumindest virtuell mit am Tisch und das
ist die Botschaft er zeigt seinem Volk
Sicherheit es ist alles wie immer
business as usual Putin hat die Lage
unter Kontrolle und Russland ist wieder
wer jetzt hat nach diesen Äußerung von
Putin beim G20 Gipfel Bundeskanzler
Scholz Putin zum Rückzug aus der Ukraine
aufgefordert welche Reaktionen sind dir
bisher schon bekannt auch aus dem Westen
auf den Auftritt von Putin
heute genau die Reaktionen sind ja
komplett nahliegend es hat ja wirklich
absurde Züge wenn der der den Krieg in
der Ukraine begonnen hat jetzt sagt es
seine Tragödie und man müsse das gemein
beenden das Beenden ist ja relativ
einfach und nahliegend nämlich ind dem
Russland die Truppen aus der Ukraine
zurückzieht das ist natürlich das was
der Westen fordert nicht nur heute
sondern auch gestern und seit nahzu zwei
Jahren seit dieser Krieg ist aber er hat
die Bühne genutzt und hat sein Statement
abgegeben mhm Amin Herr Mölling hat es
gerade einmal schon in unserem Gespräch
ein bisschen
angerissen es gibt sozusagen das ist
auch Teil dieser Analyse eine
verhältnismäßig hohe Akzeptanz in
Russland in der russischen Gesellschaft
für menschliche Verluste in
kriegerischen Auseinandersetzung wie
nimmst du die Stimmung in der russischen
Bevölkerung war auch mit Blick auf
mögliche Kriege in der
Zukunft also man muss ganz klar sagen
die russische Gesellschaft ist so
zynisch und so hart es klingt sie ist an
Krieg gewöhnt also wenn ich jetzt
zurückdenke an meine Zeit als
Erwachsener wie viele Kriege Russland da
schon geführt hat in tetchenien in der
Ukraine in Georgien in Syrien das heißt
es gibt hier keine friedensgeneration in
dem Sinne wie du und ich das aus
Deutschland sind und D das macht Putin
sich auch zu Nutze er stellt auch die
Gesellschaft auf einen langen Krieg ein
er hat jetzt z.B an an es wird jetzt
diskutiert ein generelles
Abtreibungsverbot einzuführen das heißt
die Leute haben eine vaterlandspflicht
eine patriotische Pflicht Kinder zu
zeugen für Kriege die Russland führen
wird